logan is arguably the best x-men movie
yes liberally borrowing elements from
the popular old man Logan comics arc
that story was packed with references
from the Marvel Universe and since Fox
doesn't have the rights to most of those
characters
it might seem safe to assume Logan
doesn't have many Easter eggs of its own
but you'd be wrong bub he is a spoiler
filled look at some Logan Easter eggs
you totally missed x-men number 132 one
of Logan's key plot points comes from
the old issues of x-men comics that
Laura carries around with her which
supposedly contains the coordinates for
the secret mutant Haven Enon one of
these issues is 132
while the comics they show is a proper
made for the film the decision to use
132 as the issue number isn't random at
all in the real world x-men 132 marks
the first appearance of the five Bob's
Donald Pierce one of the film's main bad
guys who battled Wolverine in that very
issue so measure Fat Albert
the evil Wolverine clone X 24 isn't in
the comics but he seems to be based on a
real character with a slightly less
scary name of Albert Albert for the
robotic version of Wolverine built by
Donald Pierce as part of a weird plan to
kill Wolverine using an Android bomb
disguised as a little girl it didn't
work but at least Albert acquitted
himself a little better in the movies
richter Rebecca Charlotte's Bobbie
Delilah
just as Laura was created using
Wolverines DNA so too were her friends
apparently created using the DNA of
other mutants one of the kids for
instance has Iceman freezing power while
another has Pyro's firepower
Logan also finds in the case files a
reference to Christopher Bradley who
appeared in x-men origins Wolverine as
part of Team X he was the mutant who
could control electricity just like the
kid who electrifies the Jeep at the end
and finally the leader of the kids
richter is a member of x-force
in the comics alkali transition the evil
corporation breeding mutant slaves
alkali transition got its really awkward
name from the comics the secret facility
where Wolverine had the adamantium
bonded to his bones by William Stryker
was actually located by acolyte Lake
which was seen in several
previous x-men movie the Reavers alkali
trans again isn't just making mutant
slaves they're also really busy
enhancing their private army of human
soldiers with mechanical arms legs and
other cybernetic doodads at one point in
the movie this gang of cyborg
mercenaries is referred to as the
Reavers which is fitting because in the
comics
the Reavers are an army of cyborgs
financed and commanded by that's right
Donald pious knickknacks considering how
eagerly Logan wants to forget his past
he carries an awful lot of mementos not
only is he toting around Chekhov's
adamantium bullets he also has a samurai
sword on the wall of his Shack as a nod
to his time spent in Japan and he
apparently bought his dog tags in bulk
of some points because he seems to have
an endless supply of the things just to
stare at it just wouldn't be a Wolverine
movie without him staring at those dog
tags Greenwood Cemetery at the beginning
of the film Logan is making ends meet to
the limo driver he ends up bringing some
random people to a cemetery where he has
his first encounter with Laura but
that's not just any burial ground
Greenwood Cemetery has appeared in
Marvel Comics for years in titles
ranging from Fantastic Four to the new
warriors Patrick Stewart's childhood
memories during a key bonding scene in
which Professor X and Laura watch the
classic 1953 Western Shane Xavier tells
her he saw the movie in the Isola dos
cinema when he was just a little kid
himself that may have actually been a
true story because as aldo was a chain
of theaters that operated in northern
england during the 1940s and 1950s when
Patrick Stewart was growing up
fascinating absolutely thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
you